bajo fuertes medidas de seguridad burlan
a rahimullah haqqani atiende a la
oración del mediodía en la escuela
coránica llame a su varilla allí se
enseña la doctrina radical deobandi de
la que salen los talibanes de la temida
red haqqani a la que se le atribuyen los
atentados más sanguinarios contra las
fuerzas de la coalición en afganistán
este es un gran momento histórico
celebramos con orgullo que hemos
derrotado a las fuerzas extranjeras
porque alá nos ha dado la fuerza el
espíritu de nuestros combatientes es muy
fuerte con la ayuda de dios y el islam
hemos ganado en octubre de 2020 mulana
rahimullah fue objeto de ataque de su
adversario rival en estado islámico del
jorasán otro grupo yihadista contra el
que combaten en afganistán en la
tentativa de asesinato murieron ocho
estudiantes en este seminario económico
de hong kong exactas idea del tapa de
cuerpo con cuatro tetrapol a nafti hemos
sacrificado diez mil combatientes
luchando contra el estado islámico
esta es la tierra de los talibanes no
vamos a dejar que sirva otra vez de
campo de batalla fuerzas extranjeras y
yihadistas que se han apartado de
alejandra equipo
los estudiantes coránicos suelen
provenir de familias pakistán ergo canas
con pocos recursos que los envían a
escuelas como esta donde reciben
educación religiosa alojamiento y comida
gratuita muchos de estos seminarios se
escapan de los ojos del gobierno y
acaban siendo centros de entrenamiento
de militantes
nuestra generación llevará el islam por
todo el mundo esta vida es pasajera en
el paraíso está la vida eterna es el
triunfo de los talibanes en afganistán
una nueva generación de estudiantes
talibanes refugiados afganos y también
pakistaníes
con el nuevo emirato islámico en
afganistán y quieren extender su
doctrina aquí en pakistán porque estos
dos países mantienen lazos históricos y
culturales porque fue pakistán el primer
país que reconoció el primer emirato
islámico en la época de los 90